This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When it comes to the thorniest issues in our lives, all of us face a dilemma. If we can't get what we want, should we settle for what we can get? We've all heard aphorisms like don't make the perfect the enemy of the good. They are designed to help us see that logically speaking incremental progress toward a goal is better than no progress. But what happens if you think something is morally wrong, but agree to change it only a little? Let's say for example, you think killing animals is wrong and it's
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当面对生活中最棘手的问题时，我们所有人都面临着两难境地。如果我们无法得到想要的，是否应该退而求其次？我们都听过诸如“不要让完美成为优秀的敌人”之类的格言。它们旨在帮助我们认识到，从逻辑上讲，朝着目标取得渐进的进步总比毫无进展要好。但如果你认为某件事在道德上是错误的，却只同意做出一点点改变，那会怎样呢？比方说，你认为杀害动物是错误的，
ethical to be a vegetarian but you've always loved meat and non-vegetarian food is an important part of your diet, culture and heritage. If you cut back on your meat eating to just a couple days a week you might reduce your consumption of meat but are you really taking an ethical stance against the killing of animals? Meat-eaters may mock you for waffling on your convictions. Vegetarians won't see you as one of them. Or let's say you were living in an apartheid state, like South Africa in the 1970s and 1980s. You're a policymaker, and you recognize
成为素食主义者是合乎道德的，但你一直热爱肉食，而非素食也是你饮食、文化和传统的重要组成部分。如果你将吃肉的频率减少到每周几天，你或许减少了肉类消费，但你真的在反对杀害动物的道德立场上采取了行动吗？肉食者可能会嘲笑你立场不坚定。素食者也不会把你视为他们的一员。或者，假设你生活在像20世纪70年代和80年代南非那样的种族隔离国家。你是一位决策者，你认识到
a system of racial segregation is unjust. You decide to make life better for some victims. Perhaps you provide better sanitation or install street lights in a poor neighborhood. Are you being virtuous or complicit? Could reforms that are merely window dressing extend an evil system by making it a little more tolerable? Over the past few weeks in our series, Us 2.0, we've been exploring how we come to disagree
种族隔离制度是不公正的。你决定改善一些受害者的生活。也许你提供了更好的卫生设施，或者在贫困社区安装了路灯。你是在行善还是在同流合污？那些仅仅是粉饰太平的改革，是否会通过让邪恶制度变得稍微可以忍受一点，从而延长了它的寿命？在过去几周的系列节目《我们2.0》中，我们一直在探讨我们是如何产生分歧的，
with each other and psychological insights to reduce conflict. If you missed any of the stories in the series, I would strongly recommend you go back and listen to them. Today, we turn to the past. We revisit a painful moment in American history and explore how a man widely recognized as one of the most important leaders in world history grappled with whether something was better than nothing when it came to the most pressing moral question of his time. Our principles and our politics. This week on Hidden Brain. There was a time in the United States when disagreements became so untenable that they actually led to war.
以及减少冲突的心理学见解。如果你错过了该系列中的任何故事，我强烈建议你回去听一听。今天，我们将目光投向过去。我们重温美国历史上一个痛苦的时刻，并探讨一位被公认为世界历史上最重要的领导人之一的人，是如何在面对他那个时代最紧迫的道德问题时，纠结于“有胜于无”的。我们的原则与我们的政治。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中。在美国，曾有一段时期，分歧变得如此不可调和，以至于最终导致了战争。
The country may well have splintered were it not for President Abraham Lincoln who led the country through the Civil War and preserved the Union. Most Americans today think of Abraham Lincoln as a statesman, a visionary, even a saint. In Washington, D.C. where I live, the Lincoln Memorial presents a portrait of the President as a hero. But the journalist Stevens keeps suggests that we often forget the most important thing about Lincoln. He was first and foremost a politician. Now, given the reputation politicians have today, that can sound almost like an insult.
如果不是亚伯拉罕·林肯总统领导国家度过内战并维护了联邦，这个国家很可能已经分裂了。今天大多数美国人认为亚伯拉罕·林肯是一位政治家、一位有远见的人，甚至是一位圣人。在我居住的华盛顿特区，林肯纪念堂将总统描绘成一位英雄。但记者史蒂夫·因斯基普认为，我们往往忘记了关于林肯最重要的一点。他首先是一位政治家。现在，考虑到今天政治家们的名声，这听起来几乎像是一种侮辱。
But in his book, Differ We Must, How Lincoln Succeeded in a Divided America, Stevens keeps suggests we all have much to learn from Lincoln. The way this politician dealt with adversaries, including people who were ostensibly on his own side, is deeply relevant to our own times. I should say this conversation is especially meaningful to me because Steve and I were colleagues for many years. Long-time listeners of Hidden Brain may recall the many conversations Steve and I had
但在他的书《我们必须分歧：林肯如何在分裂的美国取得成功》中，史蒂夫·因斯基普认为我们都可以从林肯身上学到很多。这位政治家处理对手的方式，包括那些表面上站在他自己一边的人，与我们当下的时代息息相关。我必须说，这次谈话对我来说意义非凡，因为史蒂夫和我做了多年的同事。《隐藏的大脑》的长期听众可能还记得史蒂夫和我进行的许多对话，
exploring social science research on NPR's morning edition. Steve and Skip, welcome to Hidden Brain. Delighted to be here. Good to talk with you again, Shankar. I'm wondering if you can paint a picture for me of the young Lincoln Steve. Tell me where he grew up, where he was born, what his early childhood was like. This is one of the most inspiring stories about him or really about any American political leader, because Lincoln was born at a very low station in life, not the lowest
在NPR的《早间新闻》节目中探讨社会科学研究。史蒂夫·因斯基普，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。很高兴再次与你交谈，尚卡尔。我想请你为我描绘一下年轻时的林肯，史蒂夫。告诉我他在哪里长大，在哪里出生，他的童年是什么样的。这是关于他，或者说关于任何美国政治领导人最鼓舞人心的故事之一，因为林肯出生时社会地位非常低，不是最低的，
we should emphasize, but he was from a relatively poor family, or maybe we should say an ordinary family in an era when most people were poor. In Kentucky, his father was a farmer and three times lost his farm to disputes over the land titles, which were very common in Kentucky at that time. So it's the early 1800s and three times this family without a lot of means has to move. And the final time Thomas Lincoln takes his family,
我们应该强调这一点，但他来自一个相对贫穷的家庭，或者也许我们应该说是一个普通家庭，在那个大多数人都很贫穷的时代。在肯塔基州，他的父亲是一名农民，曾三次因土地所有权纠纷而失去农场，这在当时的肯塔基州非常普遍。所以那是19世纪初，这个没有多少积蓄的家庭不得不三次搬家。最后一次，托马斯·林肯带着他的家人，
his wife, his son, his daughter, and says, I'm out of here. And they move more than a hundred miles across the Ohio River to what was then a frontier area in my home state in southern Indiana. And so this young man had to spend a lot of his childhood clearing woods to make a new farm. He said he was seven when his father handed him an axe and said, help me clear the trees. Abraham Lincoln spent a great deal of time with that axe over the next 16 years or so of his life. His was a life of farm labor, of manual labor, and only sporadic formal education. He later estimated that he only had less than a year of formal education,
他的妻子、儿子、女儿，说：“我受够了。”他们搬到了100多英里外，穿过俄亥俄河，来到了当时我所在的印第安纳州南部的一个边境地区。所以这个年轻人不得不花费他童年的大部分时间来清理树林以开辟一个新的农场。他说他七岁时，父亲递给他一把斧头，说：“帮我清理这些树。”在接下来的16年左右的时间里，亚伯拉罕·林肯花了很多时间使用那把斧头。他的生活是农场劳动、体力劳动，只有零星的正规教育。他后来估计他接受的正规教育不到一年，
a few weeks or a few months at a time when some itinerant school master would open a school for a little time in the area. His mother died when Lincoln was less than 10. His father went away for a time and came back with a new wife, a stepmother for the Lincoln children and also three new step-siblings. They all crammed into this very modest log cabin in a frontier area where Abraham was
每次只有几周或几个月，当一些流动的校董在当地开办一所学校时。林肯不到10岁时，他的母亲就去世了。他的父亲离开了一段时间，回来时带了一位新妻子，也就是林肯孩子们的继母，还有三个新的继兄弟姐妹。他们都挤在这个边境地区非常简陋的木屋里，亚伯拉罕就是在那里
growing up. You said that even though he was relatively unschooled, he did have an education of sorts when it came to his interactions with people. He was an observer of people from a very young age, and he decided he was going to learn a lot from observing people. Tell me about that, Steve. I have learned since a very young age that Lincoln's obsession with books, with reading, was central to his success. And it does seem clear that he read all the books that he could find in this frontier area. But the books were not that great. What was great was the people.
长大的。你说过，尽管他受教育程度相对较低，但在与人交往方面，他确实接受了一种教育。他从小就是一名观察者，他决定通过观察人们来学习很多东西。告诉我关于这一点，史蒂夫。我从很小的时候就知道，林肯对书籍、对阅读的痴迷是他成功的核心。而且看起来很清楚，他阅读了他在这个边境地区能找到的所有书籍。但这些书并不算太好。真正伟大的是人。
And his stepmother leaves behind this memory of young Abraham watching when grownups would come to their cabin, visitors from other farms. Abraham would sit there quietly listening to everything, listening to everything that was said. And then after the grownups went away, he would begin asking his parents questions because he wanted to understand everything that was said, and then after the grown-ups went away, he would begin asking his parents questions because he wanted to understand everything that was said. And there are further instances of Lincoln constantly observing people, watching people,
他的继母留下了关于年轻的亚伯拉罕观察大人们来到他们的小屋，来自其他农场的访客的记忆。亚伯拉罕会静静地坐在那里听一切，听所说的一切。然后在大人们离开后，他会开始问他的父母问题，因为他想理解所说的一切，然后在大人们离开后，他会开始问他的父母问题，因为他想理解所说的一切。还有更多林肯不断观察人、注视人、
studying people, and thinking about their motives, thinking about what drove them, which is exactly the thing that you would need to know later on as a political leader. As a young man, the future president moved to Illinois. An early encounter with a group of bullies revealed a lot about his methods and view of human nature. reveals a lot about his methods and view of human nature. There was a group of men from a nearby area called Clary's Grove. They were known as the Clary's Grove boys. And they were basically the male members of a clan, seven interconnected, intermarried families
研究人，并思考他们的动机，思考是什么驱动他们的例子，这正是你后来作为政治领导人所需要知道的事情。作为一个年轻人，未来的总统搬到了伊利诺伊州。与一群恶霸的早期相遇揭示了他的方法和对人性的看法。揭示了他的方法和对人性的看法。附近有一个地区叫克莱里格罗夫，那里有一群人。他们被称为“克莱里格罗夫男孩”。他们基本上是一个氏族的男性成员，七个相互关联、通婚的家庭
that had migrated out of the Appalachians. And they had a tendency to haze people to beat up newcomers in the area. And Lincoln was such a guy. And he was very tall, but the leader of this gang, Jack Armstrong was his name, challenged Lincoln to a wrestling match. There are many stories about this wrestling match. None of them is any more credible than any other, but it does appear that they
从阿巴拉契亚山脉迁移出来。他们有一种欺负人的倾向，会殴打该地区的新来者。林肯就是这样一个人。他个子很高，但这个团伙的头目，名叫杰克·阿姆斯特朗，向林肯发起了摔跤比赛的挑战。关于这场摔跤比赛有很多故事。没有一个比其他任何一个更可信，但看起来他们
faced each other, that it does appear that they faced each other, that there was a crowd, that people bet on the outcome, that Jack Armstrong was a great wrestler, but that Lincoln was larger. And they had this match that went one of several ways, depending on the various accounts, but Lincoln seems to have done well enough to have earned the respect of these guys. Now it was the early 1830s, political parties were forming. One of them was the Democratic Party. The ancestor of the same Democratic Party we have today.
确实面对面了，确实面对面了，当时有一群人，人们对结果下注，杰克·阿姆斯特朗是一位伟大的摔跤手，但林肯体型更大。他们进行了这场比赛，根据各种说法，比赛有几种走向，但林肯似乎表现得足够好，赢得了这些家伙的尊重。现在是19世纪30年代初，政党正在形成。其中一个是民主党。我们今天所拥有的同一个民主党的祖先。
The other was a party called the Whig Party, which has since gone away, but they were the opposition to the dominant Democrats. Lincoln was a Whig, or an early version of a a wig, and the bullies were Democrats. But having earned their respect, he befriended them. They became close. They went around a lot. And when a short time later, Lincoln, still in his early 20s, but an ambitious young man, declared his candidacy for the state legislature, these guys supported him in his early campaigns, even though they were from
另一个是一个叫辉格党的政党，它后来消失了，但他们是占主导地位的民主党的反对派。林肯是辉格党人，或者说是辉格党的早期版本，而那些恶霸是民主党人。但赢得了他们的尊重后，他与他们成为了朋友。他们变得亲密。他们经常一起活动。不久之后，林肯，当时才20出头，但雄心勃勃，宣布竞选州议员，这些家伙支持他早期的竞选活动，尽管他们来自
different political parties. He ended up in a situation where, even when he lost that first election, he won almost all the local votes from people of both political parties because he had reached out and made those relationships. To go back to the wrestling match for a second, you tell the story in the book about how Lincoln was not just wrestling with his arms and his legs. He was also in some ways wrestling with his words. Set the stage for me.
不同的政党。他最终处于这样一种境地，即使在第一次选举中失败了，他也赢得了来自两个政党的人们几乎所有的当地选票，因为他主动出击并建立了这些关系。回到摔跤比赛，你在书中讲述了林肯不仅是用手臂和腿在摔跤。他在某种程度上也用他的言语在摔跤。为我设定一下场景。
Yeah, I love this. We should put a little a little a risk on this in that it's hard to entirely credit any account of this wrestling match. But one of the accounts of the wrestling match seems to have Jack Armstrong saying, we're going to wrestle no holds barred, which means anything goes, anything, gouge out somebody's eye, anything you want to do, bite him, trip him, anything at all. And Lincoln replies something to the effect of, I don't want to do all this woolling and pulling.
是的，我喜欢这个。我们应该给这个加一个小小的星号，因为很难完全相信关于这场摔跤比赛的任何描述。但其中一个关于摔跤比赛的说法似乎是杰克·阿姆斯特朗说：“我们要进行无限制摔跤”，这意味着什么都可以做，什么都可以，挖出某人的眼睛，任何你想做的事，咬他，绊倒他，任何事。林肯回答说，大意是：“我不想做所有这些拉扯和推搡。”
He seems to be saying, I want rules. I want to wrestle according to a particular form of wrestling that was popular at the time. And this seems to have given him an advantage according to some accounts of the wrestling match because Jack Armstrong was not disciplined enough to follow the rules, and Lincoln was. One of the many accounts of this match
他似乎在说：“我想要规则。我想按照当时流行的一种特定的摔跤形式进行摔跤。”根据一些关于摔跤比赛的说法，这似乎给了他优势，因为杰克·阿姆斯特朗不够自律去遵守规则，而林肯做到了。关于这场比赛的众多说法之一
is that Armstrong committed a foul, and therefore was declared the loser because he committed a foul. But this is very characteristic of Lincoln and how he ran his life. Yeah. So one of the things that struck me when I read that passage is that in any form
是阿姆斯特朗犯规了，因此被宣布为失败者，因为他犯规了。但这非常符合林肯的性格以及他经营生活的方式。是的。所以当我读到那段话时，让我印象深刻的一点是，在任何形式
of combat, it makes sense to have the battlefield, if you will, your battlefield rather than someone else's battlefield. And so if the other person is going to be uncomfortable with a bunch of rules, set up a battlefield with a lot of rules. Yes, absolutely. And this is something I think Lincoln was good at. You can be rigorously fair. What is more fair than having an agreed-upon set of rules and still be thinking about your own advantage, your own self-interest, which is a thing that he thought about a lot?
的战斗中，拥有战场，如果你愿意的话，拥有你自己的战场而不是别人的战场是有意义的。所以如果对方会对一堆规则感到不舒服，那就建立一个有很多规则的战场。是的，绝对是。我认为林肯很擅长这一点。你可以做到严格的公平。还有什么比拥有一套商定的规则更公平的呢？同时还要考虑你自己的优势，你自己的利益，这是他经常思考的事情。
When we come back, the defining struggle in Abraham Lincoln's life and his early encounters with those who disagreed with him. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. From a very young age, Abraham Lincoln was an observer of people. He wasn't a psychologist, but he had a psychologist's eye for human nature. Very much like a scientist, when he encountered people whose views differed greatly from his own, his first response was not censure, but curiosity. After Lincoln was elected to the Illinois State Legislature, he met a man named Joshua Speed. The journalist Steve Inske says this ended up being a transformative relationship.
当我们回来时，亚伯拉罕·林肯生命中决定性的斗争，以及他与那些不同意他的人的早期相遇。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。从很小的时候起，亚伯拉罕·林肯就是一名观察者。他不是心理学家，但他有一双心理学家的眼睛来看待人性。非常像一位科学家，当他遇到观点与自己大相径庭的人时，他的第一反应不是谴责，而是好奇。林肯当选伊利诺伊州州议员后，他遇到了一个叫约书亚·斯皮德的人。记者史蒂夫·因斯基普说，这最终成为了一段变革性的关系。
Lincoln moved to Springfield, Illinois, was broke, was looking for housing, and met a storekeeper named Joshua Speed. Speed said, why don't you just stay with me? They ended up living together in a kind of apartment or room over the store for the next four years. What was ironic about this friendship is that while they were both from Kentucky, men who had migrated ultimately to Illinois from Kentucky, they had very, very different backgrounds because Lincoln had grown up in a poor family that was being kicked off one farm after another, Joshua
林肯搬到了伊利诺伊州的斯普林菲尔德，身无分文，正在寻找住处，遇到了一个叫约书亚·斯皮德的店主。斯皮德说：“你为什么不和我住在一起？”他们最终在商店楼上的公寓或房间里一起住了四年。这段友谊讽刺的地方在于，虽然他们都来自肯塔基州，最终从肯塔基州迁移到伊利诺伊州的男人，但他们的背景非常非常不同，因为林肯是在一个贫穷的家庭中长大的，这个家庭被一个接一个地赶出农场，而约书亚·
Speed came from a slaveholding family. He grew up on a farm where his father had grown hemp and other crops, and by the time of the father's death, he owned more than 50 human beings who worked that farm and took care of people in the house and did everything that slaves were forced to do at that time. It seems that Speed had agreed, at people in the house, and did everything that slaves were forced to do at that time. It seems that speed had agreed, at least in the abstract, that slavery was wrong, but Lincoln ultimately felt that speed was not very serious about doing anything about it.
斯皮德来自一个蓄奴家庭。他在一个父亲种植大麻和其他作物的农场长大，到他父亲去世时，他拥有50多名人类，他们在农场工作，照顾房子里的人，并做当时奴隶被迫做的一切。似乎斯皮德已经同意，在房子里的人，并做当时奴隶被迫做的一切。似乎斯皮德已经同意，至少在抽象层面上，奴隶制是错误的，但林肯最终觉得斯皮德对采取任何行动并不认真。
This is really meaningful to me, because we understand slavery is an obvious question of right and wrong, but people at the time had an immense variety of views about it. There were people who understood it was absolutely wrong. There were people who sincerely believed it was right in the way the world and the economy should be ordered. And there was a very large group of people in the middle,
这对我来说真的很有意义，因为我们理解奴隶制是一个明显的对错问题，但当时的人们对它有各种各样的看法。有些人明白它是绝对错误的。有些人真诚地相信它是正确的，是世界和经济应该被安排的方式。而在中间有一个非常庞大的群体，
people a little like Joshua Speed, who would say, slavery is wrong in the abstract, slavery is an evil, but we've inherited it, and then they would begin rationalizing in various ways why nothing really should be done about it. You see that at one point Lincoln and Speed took a riverboat trip together, where they saw something that shocked Lincoln's conscience. What happened, Steve? Yeah, well, this is one of Lincoln's extended experiences
像约书亚·斯皮德那样的人，他们会说：“奴隶制在抽象层面上是错误的，奴隶制是一种邪恶，但我们继承了它，”然后他们会开始以各种方式合理化为什么真的不应该对此做任何事情。你看到有一次林肯和斯皮德一起乘河船旅行，他们看到了让林肯良心受到震撼的事情。发生了什么，史蒂夫？是的，好吧，这是林肯的延伸经历之一
with slavery. He traveled to Joshua's Speed's farm in Kentucky, where Joshua's father had recently died, but the enslaved laborers were still there, more than 50 of them. And Lincoln, he lived in this luxurious house, a luxury he'd rarely known. Again, this is a guy who doesn't even have his own place. He's like sharing a bed with somebody else. And he's living in this place with feather beds and a cast iron
与奴隶制有关。他去了约书亚·斯皮德在肯塔基州的农场，约书亚的父亲刚去世，但被奴役的劳工还在那里，有50多人。林肯，他住在这个豪华的房子里，这是他很少知道的奢侈。同样，这是一个连自己的地方都没有的家伙。他就像和别人共用一张床。他住在这个有羽绒被和铸铁
stove and servants and black people outside are being made to work the farm. And then they start back. Lincoln and Joshua Speed are on this steamboat and they see one of the darkest realities, one of the grimmest realities of slavery, which is that people would be separated from their families, sold off and forced to go somewhere else. And for several days on a very slow, low water trip on this steamboat,
炉子和仆人的地方，外面的黑人被迫在农场工作。然后他们开始返回。林肯和约书亚·斯皮德在汽船上，他们看到了奴隶制最黑暗的现实之一，最严峻的现实之一，那就是人们会被与家人分离，被卖掉并被迫去其他地方。在汽船上一次非常缓慢、低水位的旅行中，持续了几天，
Lincoln and Speed shared the deck with a dozen men, by Lincoln's description, who were chained together and spent their days and nights like that. They had been peeled away from their families, from their wives and children and parents. And they had been chained together and sold because they were surplus goods basically. Slavery was declining in Kentucky, and so the extra human beings had to be sold off somewhere else in a market economy. And they were being shipped to the deep south, where the climate was harsher, where the labor was thought to be worse, and where they would probably die even sooner. where the labor was thought to be worse, and where they would probably die even sooner. Do we know if Lincoln spent any time talking to these enslaved people directly?
林肯和斯皮德与十几个人共用甲板，根据林肯的描述，他们被锁在一起，日日夜夜都是这样度过的。他们被从家人、妻子、孩子和父母身边剥离出来。他们被锁在一起并被卖掉，因为他们基本上是剩余商品。奴隶制在肯塔基州正在衰落，所以多余的人类必须被卖到其他地方的商品经济中。他们被运往深南部，那里的气候更恶劣，那里的劳动被认为更糟糕，他们可能会死得更早。那里的劳动被认为更糟糕，他们可能会死得更早。我们知道林肯是否花时间直接与这些被奴役的人交谈过吗？
Lincoln left two letters describing his encounter with these men. He does not quote them exactly, but he seems to have talked with them or to have learned about them in some way because he was particularly interested in one of them. A man who was a fiddler. He had a fiddle. He was playing a fiddle and leading the other men in song, which is a striking image to begin with because he's got a fetter on his wrist. He's got a chain on him, but he's still playing the fiddle. And Lincoln seems to have learned his story, that he had been sold off because of, quote, an over fondness for his wife.
林肯留下了两封信，描述了他与这些人的相遇。他没有准确地引用他们的话，但他似乎与他们交谈过，或者以某种方式了解了他们，因为他对其中一个人特别感兴趣。一个拉小提琴的人。他有一把小提琴。他正在拉小提琴，带领其他人唱歌，这本身就是一个引人注目的形象，因为他的手腕上有镣铐。他身上有锁链，但他还在拉小提琴。林肯似乎了解了他的故事，他被卖掉是因为，引用，“对妻子过度喜爱”。
We have to interpret this a little bit, this remark. It would seem that this man was enslaved in Kentucky and offended his owner, his master in some way, having to do with his wife. Maybe he was trying to spend time with his wife instead of laboring, for example. Maybe the master was more interested in this man's wife. We should put an asterisk on the word wife,
我们必须稍微解读一下这个评论。看起来这个人是在肯塔基州被奴役的，并且以某种方式冒犯了他的主人，与他的妻子有关。也许他试图花时间陪他的妻子而不是劳动，例如。也许主人对这个人的妻子更感兴趣。我们应该在“妻子”这个词上加一个星号，
because it's questionable whether enslaved people were even allowed to legally marry. But in any case, he had a family. He offended his master in some way and was sold away from his entire family and sent to hard labor that he had every reason to think was going to kill him. And that's incredibly cruel.
因为被奴役的人是否被允许合法结婚是有疑问的。但无论如何，他有一个家庭。他以某种方式冒犯了他的主人，并被卖离了他的整个家庭，并被送去从事他有充分理由认为会杀死他的苦役。这真是太残忍了。
And either by talking with him or by listening to him, Lincoln learned this man's story and couldn't get it out of his mind. Wrote a long letter about it later to a woman he had met, a relative of his best friend, Joshua Speed, who was living on that farm among enslaved people in Kentucky. Lincoln never directly says a word against slavery in the way of saying slavery is evil, but he almost journalistically describes the evils of the system that she is benefiting from, and he sends her this letter. And it's still in his mind 14 years later
无论是通过与他交谈还是听他说话，林肯了解了这个人的故事，并且无法将其从脑海中抹去。后来他给一个他认识的女人写了一封长信，那是他最好的朋友约书亚·斯皮德的亲戚，她住在肯塔基州被奴役的人中间。林肯从未直接说一句反对奴隶制的话，说奴隶制是邪恶的，但他几乎以新闻报道的方式描述了她所受益的制度的邪恶，他把这封信寄给了她。14年后，它仍然在他的脑海中，
when he writes another letter referring to this incident as something that made him miserable. So it does seem to have shocked his conscience and to have stayed with him even more than other incidents that he describes in more general terms of having encountered enslaved people. incidents that he describes in more general terms of having encountered enslaved people. So at this point Lincoln is close friends with Joshua Speed. He has lived with Joshua Speed, shared Joshua Speed's bed. He's also spent time at the Speed Plantation and in some ways enjoyed the benefits of the luxury of the plantation. But he also feels like he has serious disagreements with Joshua Speed on the question of slavery.. But he also feels like he has serious disagreements with Joshua Speed on the question of slavery.
当他写另一封信提到这件事时，称其为让他痛苦的事情。所以它似乎确实震撼了他的良心，并且比他以更笼统的术语描述遇到的被奴役的人的其他事件更让他难以忘怀。比他以更笼统的术语描述遇到的被奴役的人的其他事件更让他难以忘怀。所以此时林肯与约书亚·斯皮德是好朋友。他与约书亚·斯皮德住在一起，共用约书亚·斯皮德的床。他还花时间在斯皮德种植园，在某种程度上享受了种植园奢侈的好处。但他也觉得他在奴隶制问题上与约书亚·斯皮德有严重的分歧。但他也觉得他在奴隶制问题上与约书亚·斯皮德有严重的分歧。
And then they have this boat ride together where Lincoln sees firsthand the evils of slavery. Does he renounce his friendship with Joshua Speed at this point? Lincoln did not do what many people would have us do today with someone we encounter who holds an obviously wrong belief. did not do what many people would have us do today with someone we encounter who holds an obviously wrong belief.
然后他们一起乘船旅行，林肯亲眼看到了奴隶制的邪恶。此时他是否放弃了与约书亚·斯皮德的友谊？林肯没有做今天许多人希望我们对遇到持有明显错误信念的人所做的事情。没有做今天许多人希望我们对遇到持有明显错误信念的人所做的事情。
He did not ostracize speed. He did not break off his friendship with speed. He didn't stop talking to speed. He kept up that relationship while making it clear that they differed on this very important issue, on slavery. They remained close friends. In 1855, Lincoln wrote a letter in which he talked about their disagreement on slavery.
他没有排斥斯皮德。他没有断绝与斯皮德的友谊。他没有停止与斯皮德交谈。他保持了那种关系，同时明确表示他们在奴隶制这个非常重要的问题上存在分歧。他们仍然是好朋友。1855年，林肯写了一封信，谈到了他们在奴隶制问题上的分歧。
And again, speed had agreed in general that slavery was bad, but Lincoln thought that he was not politically serious in his positions about doing anything about it. But Lincoln then goes on to say, but if for this we must differ, differ we must. And he signs the letter, your friend forever. I find this really powerful and controversial in a way, in a modern sense, because why is he not casting aside this person who has this terrible background and seems not to have fully corrected his beliefs? Why is he not casting this guy aside?
同样，斯皮德在总体上同意奴隶制是不好的，但林肯认为他在采取任何行动的立场上并不认真。但林肯接着说：“但如果为此我们必须分歧，那我们就必须分歧。”他在信末签名：“你永远的朋友。”我觉得这在现代意义上非常有力且具有争议性，因为为什么他不抛弃这个有可怕背景且似乎没有完全纠正其信念的人？为什么他不抛弃这个家伙？
But it seems to me that Lincoln, as a human being generally, and also as an ambitious politician, understood that speed had power in this republic, that speed had influence, that he was someone to keep close, that Lincoln had personal affection for and saw personal value in, and maybe also saw political value in, and ultimately he did get political value out of this guy in his anti-slavery cause even though they didn't have exactly the same view of slavery. So when Lincoln doesn't cast speed aside, as you say, at one level, at a moral level it feels repugnant that he basically stays friends with this person. At another level, he's a pragmatist, and he's basically saying this person might come in useful to me in the future.
但在我看来，林肯作为一个普通人，也是一个雄心勃勃的政治家，明白斯皮德在这个共和国拥有权力，斯皮德有影响力，他是一个值得保持亲近的人，林肯对他有个人感情，看到了个人价值，也许也看到了政治价值，最终他确实从这个家伙身上获得了政治价值，用于他的反奴隶制事业，尽管他们对奴隶制的看法并不完全相同。所以当林肯没有像你所说的那样抛弃斯皮德时，在某种层面上，在道德层面上，他基本上与这个人保持友谊感觉令人反感。在另一个层面上，他是一个实用主义者，他基本上是在说这个人将来可能对我有用。
We might do business together. We might be able to help each other in the future. You see that one of the things that characterized Lincoln from the start was his ability to know both what he cared about, but also what he didn't care about. And to be able to prioritize them and say, I'm willing to give ground on a lot of different issues without necessarily changing my own beliefs. Can you talk about this idea, Steve?
我们将来可能会一起做生意。我们将来可能会互相帮助。你看到林肯从一开始就具有的一个特征是他既知道他在乎什么，也知道他不在乎什么。并且能够优先考虑它们，并说：“我愿意在许多不同的问题上让步，而不必改变我自己的信念。”你能谈谈这个想法吗，史蒂夫？
Yeah, I mean, that's totally true. Lincoln was a lawyer. Although he was self-educated, you could become a lawyer without going to law school and he passed an examination by a judge, became a lawyer. The record of things that Lincoln actually did in court is not that reliable, but it is at least said that Lincoln in a trial would concede a lot of points that he considered to be irrelevant while holding on to the one point that he knew would be decisive in the
是的，我的意思是，这完全是真的。林肯是一名律师。虽然他是自学的，但你可以在不上法学院的情况下成为律师，他通过了法官的考试，成为了一名律师。林肯在法庭上实际做的事情的记录并不那么可靠，但至少有人说林肯在审判中会承认很多他认为无关紧要的观点，同时坚持他知道在案件中具有决定性的那一点，
case, creating the impression that he was almost a very weak or incompetent lawyer until he won the case. Now again, it's hard to reconstruct his actual trial record, but this seems to be the way that he approached life. He would think about what was important and let go of the other things. I'm thinking of another thing, Shankar, that is reflected in this discussion of Joshua Spee. Lincoln had a particular idea of humanity, of human beings, that we were all shaped by our circumstances. He understood the power of the way that people had been brought up,
给人一种他几乎是一个非常软弱或无能的律师的印象，直到他赢得了案件。现在，同样，很难重建他实际的审判记录，但这似乎是他对待生活的方式。他会思考什么是重要的，并放手其他事情。我正在思考另一件事，尚卡尔，这反映在关于约书亚·斯皮德的讨论中。林肯对人性、对人类有一个特定的想法，即我们都是由我们的环境塑造的。他理解人们成长方式的力量，
the circumstances that they had, and also their instinctive need to follow their own self-interest. And that made him a little less judgmental of individual human beings, even when he knew they were wrong about a moral issue. He has a speech in which he's talking to a free state audience.
他们所处的环境，以及他们跟随自身利益的本能需求。这使他减少了对个人的评判，即使他知道他们在道德问题上是错误的。他有一个演讲，他在那里对一个自由州的听众讲话。
So this is at least notionally an anti-slavery audience in Illinois. And he says, if the slave owners of the South were situated as we are, they would think and act as we do. And if we in the north were situated as the slave owners are, we would think and act as they do. This is a really powerful confession, because he is saying at a really basic level, we're not morally superior to those guys, even though I believe we are taking the morally right position. He is saying we need to be humble.
所以这至少在名义上是伊利诺伊州的一个反奴隶制听众。他说：“如果南方的奴隶主处于我们的境地，他们会像我们一样思考和行动。如果我们北方人处于奴隶主的境地，我们会像他们一样思考和行动。”这是一个非常有力的忏悔，因为他在一个非常基本的层面上说，我们并不比那些家伙在道德上优越，尽管我相信我们采取了道德上正确的立场。他说我们需要谦虚。
He is saying we need to recognize that they grew up in a particular system, they inherited a particular system, and they're following their interests, which are wrong and which must be ended somehow, someday. But there is no reason to assume that we are superior to them or to take a superior attitude about them as human beings. That is really, really different than a lot of us have been educated to think about politics, particularly when it comes to issues around morality or issues around race. Back in the day, Steve, when you and I were exploring social science research on Morning
他说我们需要认识到他们成长在一个特定的制度中，他们继承了一个特定的制度，他们正在追求他们的利益，这些利益是错误的，必须以某种方式、某一天结束。但没有理由假设我们比他们优越，或者对他们作为人类采取优越的态度。这与我们许多人受教育去思考政治的方式真的非常不同，特别是在涉及道德问题或种族问题时。在过去，史蒂夫，当你和我探讨《早间新闻》上的社会科学研究时，
Edition, we often talked about an idea called the fundamental attribution error, which is an idea in psychology, which is that when we see people whose behavior differs from us, we often assume that this must be something intrinsic to the person. Someone cuts you off in traffic and you say, this person is not just a terrible driver, but probably a terrible human being. And of course what we... I probably said that the other day, but go on. But what we miss, of course, is that the other person who's speeding or cutting us off might be late for something, might be heading to a hospital.
我们经常谈论一个叫“基本归因错误”的想法，这是心理学中的一个想法，即当我们看到行为与我们不同的人时，我们经常假设这一定是人内在的东西。有人在交通中切断了你的车，你说，这个人不仅是一个糟糕的司机，而且可能是一个糟糕的人。当然我们……我前几天可能说过，但继续说。但我们错过的，当然是，那个超速或切断我们车的人可能迟到了，可能正赶往医院。
We don't understand the context and the situation that's driving their behavior. And as I read your book on Lincoln, it occurred to me that in a different life, Lincoln might well have been a social psychologist because he truly understood that the context and the environment makes a huge difference in the way we behave, the way we think. Yeah, I think that that's a great insight and a great connection. We should be careful here because someone listening might think we're trying to justify or rationalize a belief in slavery.
我们不了解驱动他们行为的背景和情况。当我读你关于林肯的书时，我想到在另一种生活中，林肯很可能是一位社会心理学家，因为他真正理解背景和环境对我们行为、思考方式有巨大的影响。是的，我认为这是一个伟大的见解和伟大的联系。我们在这里应该小心，因为有人听了可能会认为我们试图证明或合理化对奴隶制的信仰。
Slavery is wrong, to state the obvious. But what Lincoln understood was that people came to their wrong beliefs honestly, or thought they were being honest about them. And this is and was a powerful insight when you're thinking about how to try to persuade people to do something better than that, which they've been doing. So in the 1840s, Lincoln gets elected to Congress and he proposes a law that would end slavery
奴隶制是错误的，这是显而易见的。但林肯所理解的是，人们诚实地得出了他们错误的信念，或者认为他们在这些信念上是诚实的。当你思考如何试图说服人们做比他们一直在做的事情更好的事情时，这是一个强大且曾经强大的见解。所以在19世纪40年代，林肯当选国会议员，他提出了一项法律，将结束奴隶制，
but end slavery very gradually. And it has to do with children born to black parents starting in the year 1850. What does he propose? Lincoln involved himself for the first time in a substantive way in the anti-slavery debate at a moment when it was becoming the central issue facing the country. And when Congress met in what's called a lame duck session, end of 1848, beginning of 1849, Lincoln, during his single term in Congress, was there. Several people proposed to abolish slavery
但非常渐进地结束奴隶制。这与1850年开始出生的黑人父母的孩子有关。他提出了什么？林肯第一次以实质性的方式参与了反奴隶制辩论，当时它正成为国家面临的核心问题。当国会在所谓的“跛脚鸭”会议上开会时，1848年底，1849年初，林肯在他唯一的国会任期内，就在那里。几个人提议废除奴隶制
in the District of Columbia, the nation's capital, where slavery was practiced, where slavery was legal. And anti-slavery forces felt that while the Constitution, as it was then understood, protected slavery in a lot of places, made it impossible to ban slavery in a lot of places, that the federal to ban slavery in a lot of places that the federal government had authority over the District of Columbia, and here the federal government had the power to act
在华盛顿特区，国家的首都，那里实行奴隶制，那里奴隶制是合法的。反奴隶制力量认为，虽然宪法，正如当时所理解的那样，在很多地方保护奴隶制，使得在很多地方禁止奴隶制是不可能的，但联邦政府对华盛顿特区有管辖权，在这里联邦政府有权力采取行动，
and they wanted to act to ban slavery there. Pro-slavery forces in Congress didn't want any part of this to state the obvious. They slapped down a couple of bills in various ways that were raised in the House of Representatives, but then Lincoln came up with one, and he thought, if I propose a bill that abolishes slavery in a very, very gradual way, I may be able to gain the support of some more conservative, prominent citizens of Washington, D.C. He even went with this proposal to the mayor of Washington, D.C., who had come from a slaveholding
他们想采取行动在那里禁止奴隶制。国会中的亲奴隶制力量不想参与其中，这是显而易见的。他们以各种方式否决了众议院提出的几项法案，但后来林肯提出了一个，他想，如果我提出一项以非常、非常渐进的方式废除奴隶制的法案，我或许能够获得华盛顿特区一些更保守、更杰出的公民的支持。他甚至带着这个提议去找华盛顿特区的市长，他来自一个蓄奴
family but had personally freed his own enslaved labor. So this is a guy who might be at least a little bit sympathetic to the idea. And Lincoln's notion was, if we just pass this, however modest, however pathetically small this step is, it may cause a very rapid change in the composition of the District of Columbia. People may just decide they're going to free their laborers because they see the writing on the wall. And what was the proposal exactly, Steve?
家庭，但个人已经释放了他自己的被奴役劳工。所以这是一个可能至少对这个想法有一点同情的人。林肯的想法是，如果我们通过这个，无论多么温和，无论这一步多么可悲地小，它可能会导致华盛顿特区构成非常迅速的变化。人们可能只是决定他们要释放他们的劳工，因为他们看到了墙上的字。那么这个提议到底是什么，史蒂夫？
The actual text of the proposal did not free anyone who would then be enslaved in the District of Columbia in 1849. But it said that from 1850 onward, any children born to enslaved people would then be free. And they would grow up in freedom. This was what was called gradual abolition. We can look at it and see the obvious problems for that. Someone born in 1849 into slavery would remain in slavery
该提议的实际文本并没有释放任何在1849年华盛顿特区被奴役的人。但它说，从1850年开始，任何出生于被奴役人口的孩子都将是自由的。他们将在自由中成长。这就是所谓的渐进废除。我们可以看看它，看到它的明显问题。1849年出生在奴隶制中的人将保持在奴隶制中，
and if they lived into their fifties, it'd get to be 1900 and they would still be enslaved under this theory. But I think that Lincoln understood that if you get started with the process, it probably is going to go a lot faster, which turned out to be characteristic of later years when he enacted anti-slavery proposals that became real. But I think it's sort of instructive and revealing because I think Lincoln's philosophy was, if I'm trying to walk a hundred steps, it's worth walking ten, even if I can't walk the other ninety. Yes, absolutely.
如果他们活到五十多岁，那将是1900年，根据这个理论，他们仍然会被奴役。但我认为林肯明白，如果你开始这个过程，它可能会走得快得多，这被证明是后来几年的特征，当时他颁布了成为现实的反奴隶制提案。但我认为这在某种程度上是有启发性和揭示性的，因为我认为林肯的哲学是，如果我试图走一百步，即使我不能走剩下的九十步，走十步也是值得的。是的，绝对是。
And he would insist, you know, I still believe in the hundred steps. I'm not compromising my basic moral beliefs in the hundred steps by taking the ten that I can get away with now. I see in that fundamental pragmatism, a recognition of reality, that you could hold on to your highest moral beliefs and then get what you can now, understanding that democracy is a really long argument. It never ends, and so you win as much as you can now,
他会坚持说，你知道，我仍然相信那一百步。我并没有通过采取我现在能逃脱的十步来妥协我在那一百步中的基本道德信念。我在那种基本的实用主义中看到了对现实的认识，即你可以坚持你最高的道德信念，然后得到你现在能得到的，理解民主是一个非常漫长的争论。它永远不会结束，所以你现在尽可能多地赢，
then you have another election and see how much you can win next time. In 1860, Lincoln was elected president. The Civil War broke out shortly afterwards. It pitted slave-owning states in the American South against free states in the North. But this immediately produced a fresh dilemma for the new president. Was there a way to keep some slave-holding states like his own native Kentucky on his side? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
然后你再进行一次选举，看看下次你能赢多少。1860年，林肯当选总统。内战不久后爆发。它使美国南方的蓄奴州与北方的自由州对立起来。但这立即为新总统带来了新的困境。有没有办法让像他家乡肯塔基州这样的一些蓄奴州站在他这一边？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
In his book, Diffa We Must, the NPR journalist Stephen Schiepp explores the life of Abraham The NPR journalist Steve Inskiep explores the life of Abraham Lincoln. The book explores a number of disagreements Lincoln had with various interlocutors over the course of his life. Shortly after Lincoln assumed the presidency, the civil war broke out. The new president had to figure out what to do with states like his own native Kentucky. The state was amenable to staying with Lincoln and on the Union side of the war. But it was also a slaveholding state, and some of the president's advisors urged him to cast it aside. Lincoln was trying to build a majority always. As a politician,
在他的书《我们必须分歧》中，NPR记者史蒂夫·因斯基普探讨了亚伯拉罕·林肯的生活。这本书探讨了林肯一生中与各种对话者发生的一些分歧。林肯就任总统后不久，内战爆发。新总统必须弄清楚如何处理像他家乡肯塔基州这样的州。该州愿意留在林肯身边，站在战争的联邦一边。但它也是一个蓄奴州，总统的一些顾问敦促他抛弃它。林肯总是试图建立多数派。作为一名政治家，
as a political leader, that's what you want. You want a majority to win an election. As a political leader, that's what you want. You want a majority to win an election. When the South or when some Southern states began to try to leave the union, leading to the Civil War, it became an election of another kind. Lincoln needed to keep a majority of the country behind the federal government, no matter what else happened.
作为一名政治领导人，这就是你想要的。你想要多数派来赢得选举。当南方或当一些南方州开始试图离开联邦，导致内战时，它变成了另一种选举。林肯需要让国家的大多数人支持联邦政府，无论发生什么其他事情。
And that meant that he wanted to keep the loyalty of some slave states, where slavery was practiced, but the state had remained up to then loyal to the Union. You see in the first year or more of the war, multiple occasions where Lincoln stops subordinates from taking actions against slavery, the obvious cause of the war, because he doesn't
这意味着他想保持一些蓄奴州的忠诚，在这些州，奴隶制依然存在，但这些州在此之前一直忠于联邦。你可以看到在战争的第一年或更长时间里，林肯多次阻止下属采取反对奴隶制的行动——这是战争的根本原因——因为他不想
want to lose the support of slave owners who are still loyal to the union. That is the implicit and sometimes explicit reason, but behind a lot of things that he did in the first year of the war. So in 1863, he issues a proclamation that is taught in history classes all over the United States and in many other parts of the world as well. For our overseas listeners, what happened in 1863, Steve? In 1863, January 1st, 1863, Lincoln issued the final draft of the Emancipation Proclamation, which was a statement that all those people enslaved by rebels in rebel-held areas were thenceforth and forever free.
失去那些仍然忠于联邦的奴隶主的拥护。这是他在战争第一年所做许多事情背后隐含的，有时甚至是明确的原因。因此，在1863年，他发布了一份公告，这份公告在美国乃至世界许多地方的历史课上都被教授。对于我们的海外听众，1863年发生了什么，史蒂夫？1863年，1863年1月1日，林肯发布了《解放黑人奴隶宣言》的最终草案，声明所有被叛军在叛乱地区奴役的人从那时起永远获得自由。
This declared freedom for several million people at the stroke of a pen. Now, anybody who gets into the details of this finds fascinating things about it. It did not free every enslaved person in the United States. It applied only to rebel-held areas, because Lincoln was not ready to test the loyalty of those slave-owning areas that remained loyal to the Union, not ready yet. It technically did not free a single enslaved person on January 1st, 1863, because it only applied to places where federal troops did not control.
这笔一挥，就宣告了数百万人的自由。现在，任何深入研究细节的人都会发现其中引人入胜之处。它并没有解放美国境内的每一位奴隶。它仅适用于叛军控制的地区，因为林肯还没有准备好去考验那些仍然忠于联邦的蓄奴地区的忠诚度，还没准备好。从技术上讲，它在1863年1月1日并没有解放任何一个奴隶，因为它只适用于联邦军队尚未控制的地方。
But, and this is a this is a fair criticism. It's kind of crazy when you look in the exact wording, there are specific areas of the state of Tennessee that are in the Emancipation Proclamation and specific areas that are out of the Emancipation Proclamation because the state was partly but not entirely under federal control. It's kind of wild. However, it was pretty obvious where this was going, that federal troops were going to advance, that millions of people would be freed. And Frederick Douglas, who had escaped from slavery himself to become a great writer and orator against
但是，这是一个公平的批评。当你查看确切的措辞时，这有点疯狂，田纳西州有特定的地区在《解放黑人奴隶宣言》的范围内，也有特定的地区在宣言之外，因为该州部分但并非全部处于联邦控制之下。这有点离谱。然而，事情的发展方向很明显，联邦军队将会推进，数百万人将会获得自由。而弗雷德里克·道格拉斯，他本人曾从奴隶制中逃脱，成为了一位伟大的作家和演说家，反对
slavery, understood what this proclamation meant, that it was a death knell for slavery as a whole. Because he knew this partial emancipation would become a total emancipation, that once the enslaved people had been freed in the deep South, that they would also be free in the more loyal parts of the union of the Upper South. ["The Last Song of the Upper South.
奴隶制，他明白这份宣言意味着什么，它是奴隶制整体的丧钟。因为他知道这种局部的解放将成为全面的解放，一旦深南部的奴隶获得自由，他们在上南部的联邦忠诚地区也将获得自由。["上南部的最后一首歌。
Now Lincoln issued the Emancipation Proclamation and many of us today see it as a moral proclamation which of course it was, but it also had a canny political aspect to it which had to do with the service of black men in the army and in prosecuting the civil war. What happened, Steve? Yeah. Lincoln considered the freeing of a man from southern slavery as a double advantage, meaning this is just math.
现在林肯发布了《解放黑人奴隶宣言》，我们今天许多人将其视为一份道德宣言，当然它确实如此，但它也有精明的政治考量，这与黑人在军队中的服役以及进行内战有关。发生了什么，史蒂夫？是的。林肯认为将一个人从南方奴隶制中解放出来是一种双重优势，这意味着这只是数学问题。
You're taking away one laborer from the enemy, and you are likely adding this man as a soldier to the Union Army. It was a game of numbers. It was a game of building your majority, an election of another kind. The Union was on the way to winning the war, fundamentally because they had greater resources, they had more money and they had a bigger army, they had more people. greater resources, they had more money and they had a bigger army, they had more people. And Lincoln was adding to that majority by adding close to a couple hundred thousand black soldiers ultimately to the Union army, adding to the manpower advantage, even as
你从敌人那里夺走了一个劳动力，而且你很可能将这个人作为一名士兵增加到联邦军队中。这是一场数字游戏。这是一场建立多数派的游戏，是另一种形式的选举。联邦之所以走在赢得战争的道路上，根本原因在于他们拥有更强大的资源，他们有更多的钱，有更大的军队，有更多的人口。他们拥有更强大的资源，有更多的钱，有更大的军队，有更多的人口。而林肯通过最终向联邦军队增加近二十万名黑人士兵来扩大这一多数优势，增加了人力优势，即使
he was subtracting from the manpower of the other side. So it's hard in some ways to say, was this purely a moral act or was this purely a political act at some level it was both? Oh, it was absolutely both a political and moral act. Lincoln was acting on his moral belief as he put it that all men should be free. But he framed it at the time as a practical measure
他正在削减对方的人力。所以，在某种程度上很难说，这纯粹是一种道德行为，还是纯粹是一种政治行为？在某种层面上，两者兼而有之。哦，这绝对既是政治行为也是道德行为。林肯是基于他的道德信念行事，正如他所说，所有人都应该自由。但他当时将其表述为一种实际的措施，
that responded to necessity. He even defended it to racist white voters by saying, maybe you don't like black people, maybe you don't believe in equality, whatever, but this equality is good for you because it's producing soldiers for the union and undermining the enemy cause. He absolutely framed it in those terms, but he clearly was matching that practical necessity
以应对必要性。他甚至向种族主义的白人选民辩护说，也许你不喜欢黑人，也许你不相信平等，无论如何，但这种平等对你有好处，因为它为联邦培养了士兵，并削弱了敌人的事业。他绝对是以这种方式来表述的，但他显然是将这种实际的必要性
with his moral beliefs. We talked a second ago about Frederick Douglass, widely regarded today as one of the most famous abolitionists in the 19th century, a real moral force, a great writer. When Douglass was writing about Lincoln, they were ostensibly on the same side. They were both against slavery. They both wanted slavery to be done away with. But you say that for many years, Douglas was extremely critical of Lincoln. He criticized Lincoln for vacillating, for being slow, for being tardy, for moving too slowly on what was a profoundly important and moral question.
与他的道德信念相匹配。我们刚才谈到了弗雷德里克·道格拉斯，他今天被广泛认为是19世纪最著名的废奴主义者之一，一股真正的道德力量，一位伟大的作家。当道格拉斯撰写关于林肯的文章时，他们表面上是在同一阵营。他们都反对奴隶制。他们都希望废除奴隶制。但你说多年来，道格拉斯对林肯极其挑剔。他批评林肯摇摆不定，行动迟缓，在这样一个极其重要和道德的问题上行动太慢。
Paint me a picture of Douglas's criticisms of Lincoln. Douglas is the largest character in this book other than Lincoln himself. Similar to Lincoln in that he was both idealistic and pragmatic. Douglas's beliefs, to state the obvious, were absolutely against slavery, which had imprisoned him in his early years until he escaped it. He began, however, to differ with other abolitionists in how to achieve this. There was a strain of abolitionism, and Douglass's early patrons were among them, who believed that the Constitution allowed slavery and
请为我描绘一下道格拉斯对林肯的批评。除了林肯本人，道格拉斯是这本书中分量最重的人物。与林肯相似，他既理想主义又务实。显而易见，道格拉斯的信仰绝对是反对奴隶制的，奴隶制在他早年逃脱之前一直囚禁着他。然而，他开始在如何实现这一目标上与其他废奴主义者产生分歧。有一种废奴主义倾向，道格拉斯早期的赞助人就在其中，他们认为宪法允许奴隶制，并且
this so polluted the Constitution in the American political system that the proper thing to do was to ostracize it, to have nothing to do with it, to refuse even to vote, much less to hold political office, simply to stand off to the side and denounce the immorality of what was going on. Douglas came to another belief, as did other abolitionists over time, that we had a political system and that it could be used to redress grievances and that it was worth using that political system
这污染了宪法和美国政治体系，因此正确的做法是排斥它，与它毫无瓜葛，甚至拒绝投票，更不用说担任公职了，只是站在一边谴责正在发生的事情的不道德。道格拉斯产生了另一种信念，随着时间的推移，其他废奴主义者也一样，即我们有一个政治体系，它可以用来纠正不满，利用这个政治体系
to strike blows against slavery where possible. And as the civil war began, Douglas was both a supporter of Lincoln and possibly the most eloquent and powerful critic of Lincoln. He wanted Lincoln to turn the war for the Union into an explicit war for the destruction of slavery. He then was critical of Lincoln again because black soldiers were enlisted in the army
在可能的情况下打击奴隶制是值得的。随着内战的开始，道格拉斯既是林肯的支持者，也可能是林肯最雄辩、最有力的批评者。他希望林肯将这场为联邦而战的战争变成一场明确为摧毁奴隶制而战的战争。后来他又批评林肯，因为黑人士兵被征召入伍时
on less than equal terms. They weren't even getting equal pay. And he was very frank about his criticism, but he was a kind of member of the loyal opposition, if you will. He understood the broad strategic value of Lincoln and his approach, but also marked down for the world what Lincoln should have done,
条件并不平等。他们甚至没有得到平等的报酬。他非常坦率地表达了他的批评，但他可以被视为“忠诚的反对派”的一员。他理解林肯及其方法的广泛战略价值，但也为世界指出了林肯本应该做的事情，
according to Frederick Douglass. You mentioned an occasion where Frederick Douglass visited Abraham Lincoln in the White House, and at this point Lincoln is mostly familiar with Douglass from his writings, which have often been very critical of Lincoln. Now I can easily see a president saying, I only want to talk with people who say nice things about me. There are many leaders in the world today who will only talk to people who say nice things about me. There are many leaders in the world today who will only talk to people who say nice things about them.
根据弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的说法。你提到了弗雷德里克·道格拉斯在白宫拜访亚伯拉罕·林肯的一次机会，此时林肯对道格拉斯的了解主要来自他的著作，这些著作经常对林肯提出严厉批评。现在我很容易理解一位总统说，我只想和那些说我好话的人交谈。当今世界上有许多领导人只会和那些说他们好话的人交谈。当今世界上有许多领导人只会和那些说他们好话的人交谈。
But Lincoln invited Douglas into the White House and they had a very productive conversation. What happened, Steve? Yeah. It's really amazing that Douglas got in and all because Lincoln could have just turned him aside. But I think Lincoln understood the strategic value of this guy who had become a recruiter of black soldiers for the union and was now mad because the black soldiers were not getting equal treatment.
但林肯邀请道格拉斯进入白宫，他们进行了一次非常有成效的谈话。发生了什么，史蒂夫？是的。道格拉斯能进去真是太神奇了，因为林肯本可以把他拒之门外。但我认为林肯理解这个人的战略价值，他已经成为联邦黑人士兵的招募者，现在因为黑人士兵没有得到平等待遇而感到愤怒。
And within a couple of minutes by Douglas's account, Lincoln sent someone out into this crowded anti-room of dozens of people who wanted to see the president and said, send in Mr. Douglas. And it's clear from Douglas's account at the meeting at least that Lincoln was aware of Douglas's criticism, referred to Douglas's criticism and answered Douglas's criticism. He said, well, I think actually you may be right about some things. It can be said that I was slow to issue the Emancipation Proclamation, for example. But I don't agree with your criticism that I'm vacillating, that I'm a waffler, that
据道格拉斯的描述，几分钟之内，林肯就派人到外面那个挤满了想见总统的人的等候室里说，请道格拉斯先生进来。从道格拉斯对这次会面的描述来看，至少林肯了解道格拉斯的批评，提到了道格拉斯的批评，并回答了道格拉斯的批评。他说，嗯，我想实际上你在某些事情上可能是对的。例如，可以说我在发布《解放黑人奴隶宣言》方面行动迟缓。但我不同意你对我的批评，说我摇摆不定，说我优柔寡断，说我
I go back and forth. I don't think that charge can be sustained. Once I take a position, I stick with it. And Douglas found that powerful and took it as an affirmation that on slavery Lincoln was only going to move one way. He believed in the hundred steps. Maybe he could only take 10 steps today. Maybe he's only gonna take three more steps tomorrow,
反复无常。我不认为这种指控站得住脚。一旦我采取立场，我就坚持到底。道格拉斯觉得这很有力，并将其视为一种肯定，即在奴隶制问题上，林肯只会朝着一个方向前进。他相信一百步的理论。也许他今天只能走10步。也许他明天只能再走3步，
but he was only gonna keep moving in one direction. I mean, it's so striking, Steve, that when we think about the disagreements we have with others, we often focus on the issues. We focus on, you know, you believe X and I believe Y, and that's why we're in conflict with one another. But at some level, these conflicts are also interpersonal conflicts. They're also conflicts about, I don't like you or I believe that you don't like me. And in some ways, opening a conversation, being in conversation with someone, even when you're disagreeing with them, takes some of the ranker out of the disagreement. You might
但他只会朝着一个方向前进。我的意思是，这太引人注目了，史蒂夫，当我们想到我们与他人的分歧时，我们往往关注的是问题本身。我们关注的是，你知道，你相信X，我相信Y，这就是我们发生冲突的原因。但在某种层面上，这些冲突也是人际冲突。它们也是关于“我不喜欢你”或“我相信你不喜欢我”的冲突。在某种程度上，开启对话，与某人交谈，即使是在你们意见不合的时候，也能消除分歧中的一些怨恨。你可能
still disagree on the issues, but it becomes easier now to say, are there some issues on which we can march together? Yeah. Yeah. I think that's a great insight and Douglas's account of this meeting with Lincoln offers some support for that. Douglas in here, he left several accounts in the meeting, one of which was a letter right afterwards so it's fairly credible. Douglas reports not only the substance of what Lincoln explains but also Lincoln's demeanor that he has a quote transparent countenance, that he just seems real and genuine
仍然在问题上存在分歧，但现在更容易说，有没有一些问题我们可以共同努力？是的。是的。我认为这是一个很好的见解，道格拉斯对这次与林肯会面的描述为此提供了一些支持。道格拉斯在这里留下了关于这次会面的几份记录，其中一份是事后立即写的信，所以相当可信。道格拉斯不仅报告了林肯解释的内容，还报告了林肯的举止，说他有一种“透明的面容”，他看起来非常真实和真诚，
and doesn't seem uncomfortable with talking with a black man, which Douglas takes note of in his letter. Lincoln shows by his demeanor as much as his words, that he respects Douglas as a human being. And Douglas appreciates that. And Douglas comes away thinking in years afterward, I think Lincoln was kind to me in part because he could relate to me. We both had come up in very poor circumstances.
并且似乎并不因为与一个黑人交谈而感到不自在，道格拉斯在他的信中注意到了这一点。林肯通过他的举止和言语表明，他尊重道格拉斯作为一个人的身份。道格拉斯对此表示赞赏。道格拉斯在多年后回想起来认为，林肯对我友善，部分原因是他能与我产生共鸣。我们都是在非常贫困的环境中成长起来的。
I think this is generous on Douglas's part because Lincoln grew up a free man, whatever his poverty and other difficulty, which was very real, and Douglas grew up enslaved, which is clearly worse. But Douglas was willing to say, we both grew up in a hard way and we related to each other on that basic human level. And that, he seems to say, made it possible for us to collaborate and deal with each other honestly even when we disagree. I'm wondering, Steve, when you think about the role that Lincoln played and the very
我认为道格拉斯的这种看法很慷慨，因为林肯成长为一个自由人，无论他经历了怎样的贫困和其他困难——这些困难是非常真实的——而道格拉斯是在奴隶制下长大的，这显然更糟糕。但道格拉斯愿意说，我们都是在艰难的环境中长大的，我们在那个基本的人性层面上产生了共鸣。他似乎在说，这使得我们即使在有分歧时也能合作并诚实地对待彼此。史蒂夫，我想知道，当你思考林肯所扮演的角色，以及你所描绘的那个在某些方面成就卓著，但从我们的角度来看，也许做得不够快、不够早，或者不是我们可能选择的方式的人的细致画像时，你认为林肯今天能给我们带来什么教训？林肯在与他人打交道时，会设身处地为他人着想，理解他们的立场，或者至少尝试这样做。他假设其他人行事主要是出于自身利益。他试图诉诸他们作为人类的利益，并试图解释为什么，例如，
nuanced portrait that you're painting of someone in some ways who accomplished a great deal, but from our perspective perhaps didn't do it quickly enough or soon enough or in the way we might have chosen to do it. What lessons do you think Lincoln offers us today? Lincoln in dealing with the other person put himself in their shoes, understood where they were coming from or tried to anyway. He assumed that other people acted fundamentally out of self-interest. And he tried to appeal to their interests as human beings and tried to explain why, for
反对奴隶制符合他们的利益，或者说奴隶制，即内战前奴隶制的扩张，违背了普通白人选民的利益。他考虑了对方。他不一定评判对方。我认为这是一个非常、非常有力的见解。我相信，林肯比今天人们有时给予他的评价更激进。他没有把奴隶制归咎于个别奴隶主，他觉得那只是一个行为不当的人，但那是按照他所看到的自身利益行事。他指责的是制度。
example, opposing slavery was in their interest or that slavery, the spread of slavery before the Civil War, was against the interest of the ordinary white voter. He thought about the other person. He didn't necessarily judge the other person. And this is, I think, a really powerful, powerful insight. Lincoln, I believe, is more radical than he is sometimes today given credit for. He did not blame slavery on the individual slaveholder, who he felt was just a human being acting incorrectly, but acting in his interests as he saw them. He blamed the system.
他攻击奴隶制作为一个制度。这是一个我们现在有些人感到害怕的词。我们害怕谈论系统性问题、系统性种族主义。林肯所做的一切都是为了批评一个随着时间推移而发展起来，并且总有一天、以某种方式需要结束的制度。这就是林肯的洞察力。他不是为了向任何人宣扬他的道德优越感。他是为了尝试理清
He attacked slavery as a system. This is a word that some of us are now afraid of. We were afraid of talking about systemic problems, systemic racism. Lincoln was all about criticizing a system that had grown up over time and that needed someday somehow to end. This was Lincoln's insight. He was not there to proclaim his moral superiority to anybody. He was there to try to reason through
并理解社会中出了什么问题并解决它。史蒂夫，令我震惊的是，林肯似乎并不热衷于赢得道德上的胜利。他热衷于赢得政治上的胜利。是的。但通过这样做，他实际上确实取得了一场巨大的道德胜利。是的。
and understand what was wrong in society and address it. It's also striking to me, Steve, that Lincoln doesn't seem to have been in the business of scoring moral victories. He was in the business of scoring political victories. Yes. But in so doing, he actually did accomplish a tremendous moral victory. Yes.
他试图将人们的利益与他的道德感、他认为正确的事物结合起来。在他生命的晚年，他在一封信中写道：“奴隶制是错误的，我一直这样认为，我不记得有哪段时间我不是这样想、不是这样相信的。”这并没有使他在19世纪显得与众不同。数百万人明白奴隶制是错误的。即使是那些实行奴隶制的人有时也会说，
He tried to align people's interests with his idea of moral sense, his idea of what was right. Late in his life, he said in a letter, slavery is wrong, I've always believed this, I can't recall a time when I did not so think and did not so believe. This did not make him unusual in the 19th century. Millions of people understood that slavery was wrong. Even people who practiced slavery would sometimes say,
“奴隶制是错误的，但我们继承了它，它就是这样。”林肯的力量不在于他道德上如此正确，以至于他明白奴隶制是错误的。我们甚至无法在他的生活中找到某种启示，某种他理解其错误性的启示时刻。他似乎一直都明白这一点，这只是让他显得正常。林肯的力量在于找出解决办法，参与一场最终确实解决了奴隶制并（尽管通过战争）结束了它的伟大运动。史蒂夫·因斯基普是美国国家公共电台《早间新闻》的主持人。他是《我们必须分歧：林肯如何在分裂的美国取得成功》一书的作者。史蒂夫，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”节目。我很高兴能进行这次谈话。谢谢。如果这些剧集让你有所启发，我们很乐意让你与他人分享。如果你曾用它们作为与观点不同的人交流的方式，
slavery is wrong, but we've inherited it and here it is. The power of Lincoln was not in being so morally right that he understood that slavery was wrong. We can't even find in his life some revelation, some moment of revelation, when he understood the wrongness of it. He seems always to have understood that and that just made him normal. The power of Lincoln was figuring out something to do about it, taking part in a great movement that ultimately did address slavery and, albeit through a war, ended it. Steve Enskeep is the host of NPR's Morning Edition. He's the author of Differ We Must, How Lincoln Succeeded in a Divided America. Steve, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. I'm glad to have this conversation. Thank you. episodes have given you food for thought, we'd love for you to share them with other people. If you've used them as a way to engage with someone whose views are different from your own,
我们很想听听那次谈话进行得如何。你可以通过 ideasathiddenbrain.org 联系我们。那个电子邮件地址再次是 ideasathiddenbrain.org。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括 Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quirelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick 和 Nick Woodbury。Tara Boyle 是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。我们以我们姐妹播客《我未被歌颂的英雄》中的一个故事结束今天的节目。它由 T-Mobile for Business 为您呈现。Veej Berry 患有轻度脑瘫。由于这种疾病，她偶尔会绊倒和
we'd love to hear how that conversation went. You can reach us at ideasathiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideasathiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today's show with a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. It's brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Veej Berry has mild cerebral palsy. Because of the disease, she occasionally trips and
跌倒。2017 年的一天，她在华盛顿特区参加一个重要的会议。她不知道，她即将遇见她未被歌颂的英雄，凯文和玛丽。六月的那天早上，阳光明媚，非常美丽。我对自己的穿着感到非常自信。我正沿着 L 街走向我的会议地点。毫无预兆地，我摔倒了。我摔得很重。我脸朝下摔倒，眼镜割伤了我的眼睑，脸颊被划破了，我在流血。我只想跳起来抓住我的眼镜，避免进一步的尴尬。
falls. One day in 2017, she was in Washington, DC for an important meeting. Little did she know, she was about to meet her unsung heroes, Kevin and Mary. That morning in June, it was bright and beautiful. I felt very confident in what I was wearing. I was walking along L Street toward my meeting. And without warning warning I fell. I fell badly. I fell on my face, my glasses cut into my eyelid, my cheeks were torn up, I was bleeding. All I wanted to do was jump up and grab my glasses and avoid any further embarrassment.
我听到了我之前注意到站在车库里的那个男人的声音。我以为他是车库管理员。他跑向我，把我从人行道上扶起来，他带着我，实际上是冲进了一栋大楼，穿过一条办公走廊。我听到他大喊：“玛丽，玛丽，快来，这是紧急情况。”他冲进一间浴室，玛丽出现了。
I heard a voice from the man I had noticed earlier standing in a garage. I thought he was a garage attendant. He ran over to me and picked me off the sidewalk and he walked me, rushed me actually into a building and down an office hallway. And I heard him yelling, Mary, Mary, come, it's an emergency. And he rushed me into a bathroom and Mary appeared.
玛丽是大楼的礼宾员。玛丽接手了，凯文跑去拿急救箱。玛丽只是自动地，尽管我留下了一串血迹，她还是接手了，帮我清洗，洗我的脸，洗我的头发，试图把衣服上的血迹洗掉，安慰我。我在胡言乱语。我太尴尬了。但更重要的是，我感到非常沮丧，因为这种事又发生在我身上，而且是在如此糟糕的时刻，我需要去一个非常重要的地方，然而我却在这里弄得一团糟。
And Mary was the building concierge. Mary took over and Kevin ran for a first aid kit. And Mary just automatically, even though I had left a trail of blood, she took over, washing me, washing my face, washing my hair, trying to get the blood off my clothes, soothing me. I was babbling. I was so embarrassed. But more than that, I was deeply demoralized that this had happened to me yet again, and at what an awful moment I needed to be somewhere very important, and yet here I was a mess.
如果他们没有把我从人行道上扶起来，会发生什么呢？而她就在这里，试图给我包扎，让我看起来体面一些。在凯文和玛丽的共同努力下，他们帮我整理好，并鼓励我说一切都会好起来的。来自纽约克林顿的 Vige Berry。最终，多亏了玛丽和凯文的善意，Vige 赶上了她的会议。今天的《我未被歌颂的英雄》故事由 T-Mobile for Business 为您呈现。
What would have happened had they not picked me off the sidewalk. And here she was, trying to bandage me, to make me look somewhat presentable. Between the two of them, Kevin and Mary, they put me together and encouraged me that it was going to be all right. Vige Berry of Clinton, New York. In the end, Vige made it to her meeting thanks to the kindness of Mary and Kevin. Today's My Unsung Hero story was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business.
你可以在《我未被歌颂的英雄》播客或 myunsunghero.org 上找到更多此类故事。我是 Shankar Vedantan。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can find more of these stories on the My Unsung Hero podcast or at myunsunghero.org. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在《My Unsung Hero》播客或访问 myunsunghero.org 找到更多此类故事。我是 Shankar Vedantan。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。